die topleute dieses video hat es nicht
verdient auf dieser plattform zu sein
herr zu kommen so sagen die leute ich
bin heute wieder da mit einem neuen
video und zwar wir heute wieder eine
zuschauer ein sendung am start
das heutige video kommt hier drüben
sehen können von der lieben derby reding
und oder ich sag euch so viel wenn ich
heute in den titel irgendwas krasses
reingeschrieben aber was ich
wahrscheinlich gemacht habe dann geht
davon aus es ist nicht übertrieben
ok ich glaub mir dass wir sehen hier
manchmal diesen kanal videos man sich
denkt die jahr muss das sein dann gibt
auch diese andere kategorie von videos
man sich denkt da dann gibt es noch
diese kategorie von video die welt
anschauen werden
was uns heute anschauen werden ist ein
youtube video von vielen für alle die
nicht wissen wer oder was die
landestellen ist eine freundin von
becker in einer anderen deutschen
güterbahn auf den videos ja ab und zu
mal reagiere die lahn hat mittlerweile
alle ihre videos auf privat gestellt im
kreisel keine videos mehr das video was
uns das anschauen werden ist ein upload
und ja schauen einfach mal rein
[Gelächter]
das wird eine ganz schlimme dabei heute
leute wir sehen schon mal ein bild wo
wir uns als geneigter youtube zuschauer
des spielers ab wo wir uns als geneigter
youtube zuschauer denken
[Musik]
für alle die das damals mitbekommen
haben erstmal herzlichen glückwunsch an
euch ihr habt definitiv ein leichteres
leben es ist nämlich so dass diese viel
an dieser an youtube diese freundin von
becker ring immer auch game master
videos gemacht hat also game master
können wir wahrscheinlich alle
irgendeine eine ausgedachte charaktere
wo leute so tun als würde dieser
charakter sie verfolgen und dann darüber
videos machen aber diese ziele hat diese
game master videos immer in eine richtig
seltsame richtung gemacht also alle
anderen so videos gemacht zu haben heißt
das verfolgt mich und sie landen war so
der game master fiel mir irgendwas
irgendwo reinschieben
ok stopp stopp stopp an der stelle
direkt unterbrechen können wir direkt
pause machen leute
wo ist der gottverdammte oscar für diese
frau was dachtet ihr wer dieses jahr den
oscar bekommt leonardo dicaprio matt die
mconie tom hanks na dann bekämpft
ja wieso fiel an wieso wieso hast du
jemals in deinem leben gedacht dass es
ohne gottes geht nicht meinen kopf sein
dass das eine gute entscheidung wäre
dieses video zu machen wer ich will's
wissen von euch leute
wer sitzt bei sich zu hause denkt sich
ich hab's alter der nächste banker auch
beim kanal wird sein dass ich mich nackt
auf die straße laufen den scheißdreck
[Musik]
leute in ruhe in frieden für meine linke
gehirnhälfte die jetzt nämlich gerade
komplett verabschiedet er den dienst
quittiert
naja ok alles klar wie es kann eben
schon gesagt habe ist es ein game master
video natürlich für unsere liebsten wie
es auf dieser plattform sind einfach
game master videos priwalls einfach
sehen wie junge deutschsprachige frauen
so tun als würde eine figur mit einer
maske sie verfolge und das allerbeste
ist es wirklich das allerbeste ist es
wenn so ein müll dabei herumkommt nackt
auf der straße aufgewacht wegen game
master möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
ich hoffe dieses video schaut keiner
person die mit mir verwandt ist oder die
mit mir im echten leben irgendwas zu tun
hat nur für euch da draußen weiß jetzt
was jedoch ihr seid das ist nicht
youtube okay nicht alle sind so wie sie
es gibt auch gute menschen hier
lange rede pause wo sie wahrscheinlich
gerade die existenz überdenkt wir müssen
auch dabei festhalten leute das hier ist
so wie es aussieht ein wohngebiet
ja also viel an wohnt ja irgendwie in
amerika oder hat man am montag voll für
die videos in amerika gedreht also wo es
aber nicht mehr starten das ist
höchstwahrscheinlich ein wohngebiet in
den vereinigten staaten und diese frau
legt sich ich kann es mir in worte
fassen
fakt sich da einfach auf den asphalt
sorry aber da ist doch irgendeine
geistige störungen spielt zur
altersklasse
die kamera ist da und wir sehen würde
sogar auch aufnehmen gedrückt bei der
kamera die topleute dieses video hat es
nicht verdient auf dieser plattform zu
sein
[Musik]
es ist ein ernst das ist somit das
schöne daran leute wenn solche menschen
solche youtuber game master wie es auf
dem oder allgemein so wie es auch in
diesem bisschen wie jetzt stellen die
meistens im video schon genau die fragen
die sich eigentlich auf sich selbst
stellen sollten ja fragt dich mal selbst
warum bist du auf der straße gelandet
war warum machst du das alter komme auf
dein leben klar kannst du doch was
abgeht wird sich irgendwo in den
vereinigten staaten nackt auf den
asphalt gepackt ja aber dann fragst du
die kamera was falsch ist auf dein leben
klarkommen ab in die geschlossene
psychiatrie instant erschwerend dazu
dass viele auch game master immer so
komisch aus sprich also sie sagte nicht
game master sowie alle deutschen sondern
game master ja okay wir wissen wo wohnen
sie in den vereinigten staaten jetzt
frater gar nicht mal so schlecht auf
barfuß zu laufen was denkt ihr was das
ist ein erster gedanke diese situation
gar nicht weil sie schlecht barfuß zu
laufen
ok alles klar lasst euch einfach mal so
stehen und die nächste frage was denken
wir ja was denke ich
ich denke ich habe keinen bock mehr auf
dem dobel ziegel ich bin ich habe das
gefühl ich bin jetzt in der wildnis
nichts macht sind in diesem video
siehst du was du da gerade macht hörst
du dir selbst zu du stehst literally vor
einem haus du stehst in einem wohngebiet
verdammte axt okay was sagt sie ok ich
glaube ich bin in der wildnis naja ok
also wir sind hier auf dem park und
dieser park ist einfach mal vier oder
fünf minuten von mir entfernt und damit
mitten in der wildnis im park mitten im
wildnispark heute wir sehen zum
hintergrund wuchernde wildnis die
gewächse die pflanzen die tiere sind
vollkommen außer kontrolle es stehen zur
mitte und ein paar sehr gepflegte häuser
und auch der rasen ist äußerst gut
gepflegt und perfekt gemäht aber wir
sind mitten in der wildnis leute glaubt
es mir einfach es ist mir geheiß heute
aber zum glück haben wir gutes wetter
ich werde mich zu gemein sein aber es
springen doch einfach mal rein
ein paar leute habe ich schon
angesprochen ob ich ihn gehhilfe brauche
leute sag ich es nicht die ganze zeit
alle diese game master und komische wird
es drei uhr nachts anrufen cup misst
youtube stellen sich immer die richtigen
fragen selbst beantworten sie doch
einfach mal leute haben sich gefragt ob
du hilfe brauchst ja darauf
ergänzend zu dieser wirklich wunderbaren
genialen und sehr schön video idee die
man sie an verantworten
sicherlich an stellt man sich einfach so
denkt da wird einem richtig warm ums
herz kommt noch ihre aussprache weil sie
kann ich irgendwie normal deutsch reden
und mein gott dann geht es von gamestar
aber egal solange wir in der sonne sind
ist alles gut
naja
im hintergrund rennen die ersten
menschen weg vor angst vor verwirrung
leute übrigens das ist wieder so eine
sache die geht mir gerade dich wirklich
über die lippen
aber ich will es zumindest mal sagen
diese stelle ist gerade passiert und ich
habe sie bewusst nicht in dieses video
gepackt leute was hat die lernen gerade
eben einfach gemacht diese geisteskranke
hat gerade eben einfach so gesagt hey
leute ja jetzt zeigt ihr euch noch mal
dass ich wirklich nichts drunter annahme
und macht aber so das hatte auch die gea
zensiert anders aber kommst du nur noch
ansatzweise klar in deinem kopf
vorgespielt leute auf einmal sieht das
bild einfach so raus hier
sorry für die qualität ich benutze
halten handy weil der gamer steuer nur
mein handy gebracht hat
[Gelächter]
benutzen und handy ist neben handys
immerhin so der wellenform auf dass das
komplette vize gewählt ist warte ich mal
auch kurz ich mach kurz ein handy dahin
wo meine kamera ist ja schrecklich will
uns gerade ein handy handys sind nicht
in der lage normale videos aufzunehmen
naja deutlich das doppel aber ich schaue
mir gerne mal die kommentare was ihr von
diesem meisterwerk haltet und ob ihr
auch meiner meinung seid wenn ich sage
dass diese videos von dieser art hier
nichts auf youtube verloren haben
dietrich vorgeschlagen ist davon aber
nicht hier oben unbedingt meinen kanal
um mitglied bei den kanal zu werden und
ich küsse augen heute liebe grüße an
jeden einzelnen von euch da draußen
macht's gut